the way we tell stories has naturally
changed since Aristotle defined the
rules of tragedy about 2500 years ago
according to him the role of
storytelling is to mimic life and make
us feel emotions and that's exactly what
story telling us we know it it's done
very well since then but there is a
dimension of life that storytelling
could never really reproduce it is the
notion of choices choices are very
important part of our lives we as
individuals are defined by the choices
we make some of our decisions can have
very significant consequences and
totally change the courses of our lives
but in a play a novel or a film the
writer makes all the decisions in
advance for the characters and as the
audience we can only watch passively the
consequences of his decisions as a
storyteller I've always been fascinated
with the idea of recreating this notion
of choices in a fiction my dream was to
put the audience in the shoes of the
main protagonists let them make their
own decisions and by doing so let them
tell their own stories finding a way to
achieve this is what I did in the past
20 years of my life today I would like
to introduce you to this new way of
telling stories a way that has
interactivity at its heart rather than
you know exposing the theory behind it
which could have been kind of abstract
and be probably a little bit boring I
thought it would be a great opportunity
to do a little experiment I would like
you the people here in Ted to tell your
own story
so I came with an interactive scene that
we are going to play together I've asked
Nikki hello Vicki to control the main
character for us and you roll you the
audience will be to make the choices so
Vicki and I don't know what's going to
happen because it will all be based on
your decisions so this scene comes from
our next game called Detroit become
human and we are in the near future
where technology made possible the
creation of androids that look exactly
like human beings so we are in the shoes
of this character called Connor wiesen
Android and he can do very fancy things
with coins as you can see he has this
blue triangle on his chest as all
androids do and now Vicky's in control
of this character she can walk around
she can go anywhere she can look around
she can interact with her environment
and now she can tell her own stories by
making choices so here we have our first
choice there is a fish on the ground
what should we do should we save it or
should we leave it remember we're under
time pressure so it better be fast what
should we do
hey let's have the fish here we go okay
we have an Android who likes animals
okay let's move on remember we have a
hostage situation
okay she's not truly happy my daughter
has been taken hostage by an Android and
of course she's in state of shock it's
okay now we can continue to explore this
apartment we see all the swats what
forces in place but we need to find his
captain island first that's the first
thing we need to do so again we can go
anywhere
Vic is still in control of the character
let's see oh I think this is Captain
Aden is on the phone captain
my name is car
it's fine everything moves it already
shot down two of my men we can easily
get it but they're on the edge of town
if it falls
[Music]
okay now we need to decide what we want
to ask the captain what should be our
choice
deviance name divisions behavior
emotional shock has it experienced an
emotional shock
does it matter I need information to
determine the best approach okay a
second choice maybe we can learn
something what should we choose okay
deviant behavior strangely okay we are
not going to learn anything from this
guy I mean we need to do something okay
let's let's try to go back in the lobby
oh wait there's a there's a room over
there on your right Vicki I think maybe
there is something we can learn here oh
there's a tablet let's have a look
that's was just one way of playing the
scenes but there are many other ways of
playing it depending on the choices you
make we could have seen many different
actions many different consequences many
different outcomes so that gives you an
idea of what my work is about as an
interactive writer where a linear writer
needs to deal with time and space as an
interactive writer I need to deal with
time space and possibilities I have to
manage massive tree structures where
each branch is a new variation of the
story I need to think about all the
possibilities in a given scene and try
to imagine everything that can happen I
need to deal with thousands and
thousands of variables conditions and
possibilities as a consequence where a
film script is about 100 pages an
interactive script like this is between
four and five thousand pages so that
gives you an idea of what this work is
about but I think in the end the
experience is very unique because it is
the result of the collaboration between
a writer creating this narrative
landscape and the player making his own
decisions telling his own story and
becoming the co-writer but also the co
actor and the co director of the story
interactive storytelling is a revolution
in the way we tell stories with the
emergence of new platforms like
interactive television virtual reality
and video games it can become a new form
of entertainment and maybe even a new
form of art I am convinced that in the
coming years we will see more and more
moving and meaningful interactive
experiences created by a new generation
of talents this is a medium waiting for
its Orson Welles
or its Stanley Kubrick and I have no
doubt that they will soon emerge
and be recognized as such I believe that
interactive storytelling can be what
cinema was in the 20th century an art
that deeply changes its time thank you
[Applause]